I don't feel I inherited
an English department,
I feel someone handed me
a ticking time bomb
because they wanted a woman
holding it when it explodes.
By now, you've probably
finished The Chair,
Sandra Oh's pin-sharp
comedy drama
detailing the embattled
daily life
of the first woman
appointed as Chair
of the English Department
at a top-tier university.
And like all good students,
you've probably
got questions.
Let's go!
Is The Chair
based on a true story?
It's not.
It's an original idea
created by Amanda Peet
and Annie Julia Wyman.
The institution, too,
is fictional.
Instead of being
a real place,
Pembroke University feels
like an amalgamation
of numerous elite
US learning institutions.
Everyone in this looks
familiar, who's in it?
She doesn't need an intro,
but Sandra Oh
of Grey's Anatomy
and Killing Eve
stars as Ji-Yoon Kim,
the first female chair
at Pembroke University.
It's one of those
first dedicated
comedy series roles,
although both Killing Eve
and Grey's
obviously had their moments.
Jay Duplass of Transparent
is Professor Bill Dobson,
a self-destructive widower
who becomes mired
in controversy.
Heil Hitler.
And you'll recognise Emmy
Award-winner Holland Taylor,
who delights as the savage
Professor Joan Hambling,
from loads of stuff.
Well, I hope they didn't
have to look at your fanny
while you did that.
Including The Practice,
Legally Blonde
and The Truman Show.
More recently, in 2020,
she appeared
as the lovable Stormy
in To All The Boys 2,
and was nominated
for an Emmy
for Ryan Murphy's Hollywood.
Acting isn't magic.
It's a job.
Nana Mensah from
Queen of Glory and Bonding
is Professor Yaz McKay,
and Bob Balaban
from The Monuments Men
and basically
every Wes Anderson movie
since Moonrise Kingdom
is Professor Rentz,
the old-school academic
threatened by
the ascendant McKay.
David Morse from The
Green Mile is Dean Larson.
And the show
is partly stolen
by 7-year-old Everly
Carganilla of Yes Day,
who features as Ju Ju,
Ji-Yoon's wonderful,
complex,
slightly terrifying
adopted daughter.
Do you have fur
on your vagina?
And David Duchovny
is played by, yes…
David Duchovny
of The X Files fame.
Wait, did David Duchovny
really go to Princeton?
Yeah! And, in fact,
loads of the stuff
said about Duchovny,
who plays himself
in the show,
is actually based on fact.
Interesting.
He attended
Princeton University,
where he graduated in 1982
with an A.B.
in English Literature.
And, yes,
that really is the title
of Duchovny's dissertation.
"The Schizophrenic Critique
of Pure Reason
in Beckett's Early Novels".
I only wrote
the one chapter.
The only difference is that
he wrote it at Princeton,
not Yale,
although he did go to Yale,
earning a Master of Arts
in English Literature
before starting work
on an unfinished PhD
on Magic and Technology
in Contemporary Fiction
and Poetry.
Yes, really.
Oh, and the music stuff
is real too.
In 2007, he put
his acting career on hold
to spend more time
as a singer-songwriter.
I'll have a mind of winter
Only song I've ever heard
quote Wallace Stevens.
Fuck, I hope so.
D.B. Weiss
and David Benioff?
Why do those names
sound familiar?
Come on! This is Weiss
and Benioff's first series
since Game of Thrones
ended in 2019,
although this time they're
producing not writing.
Dirty John and A Lot Like
Love star Amanda Peet
takes the lead
as executive producer
and showrunner of The Chair.
And it's written by Peet,
cocreator Annie Julia Wyman,
Richard E. Robbins,
Jennifer Kim
and Andrea Troyer.
Where is The Chair set?
The Chair was filmed
in Pittsburgh in early 2021,
presumably in winter
looking at the scenery,
and much of the show
is set in the city's
Lawrenceville neighbourhood.
The city has
three universities:
Carnegie Mellon University,
the University of Pittsburgh
and Duquesne.
But as we mentioned before,
Pembroke is
entirely fictional.
What is Doljabi?
It's a long-standing
Korean tradition
to celebrate
a baby's first birthday
with a grand ceremony
called Doljanchi.
This is the event Bill
ends up sort of gatecrashing
in Episode Five,
'The Last Bus in Town'.
The highlight
of the ceremony is Doljabi.
The child is placed
in front of a selection
of six to eight items then
encouraged to grab them.
The items they pick
represent their future,
whether it's
a particular career, wealth
or lifestyle.
In The Chair,
Minji's options
are represented
by a stethoscope,
pencil, paintbrush,
money, tennis ball
and white string.
But really the items
can be anything
that represents
a particular future,
from space rockets
for astronauts
to microphones
for performers.
This isn't authentic!
She's clearly tampering
with the process right now.
Let her make her own choice.
What is Día de los Muertos?
Día de los Muertos is
a Latin American holiday
with strong associations
to Mexico,
celebrated on
the 1st of November.
It honours the dead with
festivals and celebrations,
combining indigenous Aztec
ritual with Catholicism
brought to the region
by Spanish conquistadors.
The idea is that the dead
would be insulted
by mourning or sadness,
so Día de los Muertos
celebrates their lives
instead.
As well as the celebrations,
the dead are celebrated with
something called ofrendas,
small personal altars
honouring one person.
Ofrendas are decorated with
things like flowers, candles
and mementos of the person
being remembered,
which is exactly what Ju Ju
helps Bill to create
for his late wife.
She's gonna find you.
What is tenure
and why is it so important
to Professor McKay?
This one will be pretty
obvious to US viewers
but perhaps less so
to those elsewhere.
Tenure is a permanent
academic appointment,
which can only be terminated
in exceptional
circumstances.
As well as providing
security and influence,
it also affords a degree
of academic freedom.
Your university
isn't gonna get rid of you
for researching the wrong
thing, for instance.
That's why it's so important
to Nana Mensah's
Professor Yaz MacKay.
It's a sign she's made it
as an academic.
And although she's
an established and important
member of the teaching staff
at Pembroke,
she'd be in a much better
position if she was tenured.
Thank you so much
for agreeing to chair
my tenure case.
Ji-Yoon gave me the news.
Surely.
Will there be a second
season of The Chair?
Honestly, we don't know yet.
Let's hope so.
Here's a montage
of Professor Hambling
to keep you busy.
Philandering husbands,
horny housewives,
farting…
pubic hair.
Some poor schmuck asks
a woman for a kiss
and ends up making out
with her butthole.
I'm what he thinks about
when he's trying not to cum
in his girlfriend?
I don't get it.
For example, it would
be true for me to say,
everyone can see your fanny.
You're a tiger!
Get in there!
Do it, Joanie!
People,
let's try not to panic.
Well, that's easy for you
to say, you're 51.
I'm 46.
You're kidding.
Did you enjoy The Chair?
If you were writing
a dissertation
on Netflix shows,
what would it be?
Let us know in the comments.
And remember to subscribe
to the channel now
for more videos about your
favourite shows and movies.